aos 20
é bom que a pessoa agora tô - no último
ano no site da rede o careca deu o que
aconteceu o fato
é eu tinha um percurso normal secundário
também entender é para usar a engenharia
sempre o aluno
apesar de ter sempre ideias alternativas
dando como e encarar o estudo isso
entrou na banda eu vou falar muito mais
liberto eu era capaz de servir no futuro
sem 100 anos em geral os jogos da china
nesse caso os romanos quando acaba o
problema muscular seguir na primeira
investida da aventura
eu sempre casa primeiro é é um toque de
experiência é sempre muitas vezes na rua
ou melhor quase nenhum país reconheceu a
senhora ficou com guitarra que estava a
ficar fora de horas próximas
tudo isso me deu experiência e confiança
para voltar a tentar algo que foi uma
coisa que eu voltei a fazer depois nos
convém recordar no fim e também nas
férias bravura dois meses na europa onde
isso a europa o ex guia e república
checa até o norte da escandinávia
noruega suécia e do qual portugal está
mais confiante sabendo como companhia
desenrascar uma forma mais produtiva na
rua e e foi mesmo vindo a conseguir
ganhar dinheiro suficiente pra ter uma
diferença de qualidade e conseguir de
facto é aproveitar a experiência desta
vez no fim do meu terceiro ano de
serviço aqui mesmo em que não estava não
estava ainda privada não estava ainda
concluído este conjunto de experiências
que eu precisava ter aulas acontece mais
impacto e então decidi que para fazer
três para fazer isso para fazer uma
viagem com maior duração tinha mesmo
plano aplicado durante o curso que foi
uma grande decisão que também porque ela
vai acabar o curso e portanto é uma
coisa é uma coisa complicada porque o
eu nem que eu voltar eu queria saber de
voltar mas é só isso
quem é que sabia ser a mesma que eu
queria atrasar bastante satisfeito mas
como conhecer melhor o golpe
isso é alguma idéia que eu vou aqui
defender que é que é mesmo crucial
nós contamos abordava existe há 15 anos
ao afundar estiver logo entrar na
faculdade e os oito anos em que somos
muitas vezes em oito anos e incapaz de
decidir o que iremos fazer para o resto
da vida e uma decisão assim tão
importante porque é também fundamental
que nós possamos nós próprios e então
com isso é que eu consegui fazer essa
viagem seguir com o seu eventual apoio
eles forma todo tipo de problemas que
parecem surgir mas aí eu estava lá pra
enfrentar sem sozinho sem qualquer e aí
com um ambiente eo passaporte - foram
foi tudo o que eu vi foi tudo que eu ia
trazer também a bagagem foi sem
surpresas mas fomos eu eo ps casa
o balé ea apanhar banho é o último da
série pode ser com um humano como uma
triagem só hoje pouca facto é quem para
acaba por ser aquela pessoa que estava à
disposição ter um um momento em que
enfrenta tinha uma oportunidade de
conhecer alguém novo
e então facto eu nunca nunca nunca um
campeão em todas as milhares doença que
até agora nunca é uma coisa podem
transformar intenções poderia ter
surgido existem essas pessoas não não
creio que seja uma coisa nada provável
até é e não é percebido como conseguia
como consegui apanhar mais nascimentos
que era é para gestores que estava
parado na estrada a gente aqui o exemplo
de como não se deve fazer em toda a
estrada demorar muito mais tempo de
viajar estão a serviço da auto-estrada é
muito mais rápido porque as pessoas já
vão na direção de longas distâncias
ainda criança viu que eu pertencia e
então eu consegui acusar diretamente a
pessoa ela consegue se perceber
tanto o meu caráter é mais ou menos
porque o agora de uma forma gentil e
tentou tentou fazer ela compreendeu dós
quais são os meus objetivos e então é
ter ou a pessoa a oportunidade fazer
alguma sabedoria que é uma coisa
maravilhosa e então partir daqui é o mel
é uma paisagem que ouvia muitas vezes
encontrava na cabine do caminhão
então vou pensar apura a minha primeira
apresentação é uma linda jovem também a
música você mudar formas diferentes
agora e desde já peço desculpa por não
cantar em português mas é uma questão
física
acho que ele ia tratar viagem da quinta
mas é uma homenagem mais globalmente
aventura de ser amigo
é samba bom essa não quero falar
josé é ter nossa visão
eu não quero ter
se eu vou contar um pouquinho de como
foi acompanhar minha história lá que
seja convocada com caráter muito pessoal
porque eu escolhi meu caminho apesar de
não ter sido nada traçado muito estrito
porque nunca conheci eu estava sempre
sujeito a altos do que o outro quer
acontecendo e todos os nossos produtos
levaram até os conseguirem ter duas
oportunidades neste caso e traz pra em
frança e tal eu tenho fé e para a grécia
é muitas situações que ainda assim não é
por exemplo a quem não tem parecer uma
fotoinstáveis foi pra outra coisa mais à
frente
ainda assim eu tinha dinheiro tinha
tocado na estação pra conseguir o
dinheiro para pagar esses ferry é as
pessoas lavra do do adeus disse que
estavam tanto que acabaram por 15
minutos do fim de ir embora o ferry
obter um dia porque não estava cheio de
tudo eu tenho que ficar um dia que pode
atrapalhar mas a viagem pois todos é
gracie é turquia e se eu estou com
poucos registros da minha viagem neste
caso todo mundo quer mostrar uma foto da
turquia e se não perturbar uma do
maranhão vai ver um gato que eu vou
contar algumas histórias
então eu depois do ato a seguir para o
iraque o irão e vão juntar alguns
interessantes que eu sempre fui o
primeiro sido uma coisa já que quer
dizer que eu tenha três regras na minha
viagem é que é o principal torneio tinha
que gastar em setembro para cumprir
promessa aqui como tirar o curso é que o
esforço que eu fiz porque é apesar de
tudo de bom que consegui me agüentarem
em quase todos os sítios web no qual
viajavam de uma vida estável amigos e eu
ia cumprir à risca as quisesse mas
obviamente e agora contemplando as redes
sociais é muito fácil manter os contatos
do avião sejam salvas quiser montar três
oportunidades
o irão tem uma frase que o poeta la rosa
que
nag um monte de açor aqui mas nada mas
isto vai é um é o grito insurgência que
é uma coisa gostosa dos engenheiros vão
precisar apesar de eu estar e viver tudo
isso mas hoje em tartar primeiro é e com
para roubar as pessoas é uma das bandas
que nunca acham que essas coisas podem
dar errado é impossível aprender nunca é
bom perder a força nunca vou poder à
força enquanto é não deixar comentários
e sugestões também em seguida pois não
tinha visto caminharam pelo bairro vai
coisas fantásticas devem ter como
gravatas e tentar o benefício
depois passei para o mar mexido proposta
interessante eu não consegui fazer isso
tudo vai chegar por terra com o
paquistão também no dia 9
então fui para o homem surgiu uma das
áreas mais complicadas que eu vou então
tentar encontrar mais rapidamente o que
é possível ser preso porque invadiu o
palácio da sultan conhecia o palácio
construído por portugueses então eu
tenho toda a vontade de misturar não é o
legado que se criar produtos novos na
altura que encontrei na entrada
principal da administração da muralha e
do mar deixa lá pois não foi empenhado é
encabeçar uma cela uma cela e daí foi
interrogado especial mesmo acho que é um
problema há razão para alarde
portanto é que acabar o curso passado em
que o praticante na história - dispensar
a mensagem
ninguém parecia até mesmo o chefe da
unidade onde se o santos passar a noite
em que estou é preciso da minha história
eu estou eu e meu espírito e acabou por
me ajudará a a apreciar pratos ainda que
foi possível mas é f x2 economizar no
facebook pois acabei por todos em algum
dinheiro que tinham dados de sua graça
no bairro europeu para parcelar que a
senhora quer passar muitas histórias uma
delas foi testado nas linhas 1 284
pessoas linho e não tinha dinheiro pra
passar para a índia que era preciso voar
porque não me deixaram passar muito
perto do mar e ainda sem cordas bandolim
foi uma coisa extraordinária
depois eram as cordas e conseguiu tomar
a vida das ruas
vou cantar uma música nunca aprenderam
que critica vida é um é uma viagem e os
programas foi o futuro ninguém sabe
essa vai soar que a roda
o paraná sai carol 10 mas não na guerra
em haia lhe dizer é da rega ea um cap a
morte que isso deixará ea o craque arroz
smel para então fazer muitas coisas e eu
fui pra a aneel hélvio porque era o
grito que ganhou e foi titular e não
saiu da minha vida com o são paulo
com isso com isso as rodadas vão ser as
básicas cliente nos terminais e para
toda a vida mas mesmo reprovou seria
sensível dessa forma então que mumbai
afirmou sentir ficar no rio fui alguém
de sua tela com seus produtores
depois acaba por fazer um canal de tudo
aprender uma câmera está aqui sob uma
disciplina para ir embora na altura da
explosão uma câmera para mel eu gravei
os filhos em estúdio e depois da quinta
posição é o acidente foi na minha casa
como foi uma relação muito próxima das
pessoas sempre vão faltar os outros sem
dúvida uma vez voltar pra aquela aquela
música do próprio foi acabei por efron
se dissipam paulo é foi o brasil é certo
que eu ia só
mas lá fora lá fora podemos falar com
mais calma tendo eu ia mostrar isso aqui
era o curso do rio doce malaias os novos
vídeos no youtube quer ficar preso ao
tentar isso
a música é jardim i bom é sangue e ver a
mim que lá lá essa
isso aqui é uma casa de uma tia da de
amor em que entra uma das cenas go
sandes se nos voos extra que temos lojas
com os himalaias
acho que merece
o andré é que vai passar a passagem dela
vai cima é que também no natal ainda
conseguir levar nada porque isso aqui é
zero não é né acometeu china popular da
candidatura exigiria que o na altura
seria homenageado com uma bandeira pra
tocar lá que está acontecendo estou
vendo a causa também por aqui para
marcar o primeiro aniversário lá na
altura por vencer o grupo português em
questão já divulgada na comunicação
social a próxima etapa final da causa é
necessário nesse caso e mail e comprei
um vôo para pra ver com que o resto é
saltar do assalto aconteceu foi um
suicídio é a lazio
eu pensei eu vi lá posso fazer isso com
o senhor músicos e depois vai apresentar
uma o autor não saía eu fiz uma tatuagem
na altura é um êxito o significado que o
piloto pode país chama-se bunga tem um
significa flor em gel a é que é o da
flor é o ritual de passagem que afloram
ser um fruto ou seja é um crescer mais o
crescimento do útero e também no centro
em uma espiral que é o girino também
aquela que é uma mudança depois ficou
com um algo mais ou menos assim mesmo
instante porque eu vim aqui não tinha
mérito é portugal não consegue a certeza
que poderei aprender é pura está na
austrália estava também será nessas
coisas
salve ó maior à dinho naiá também é mãe
de carol e se jogou
é na unha na célula obras mal o meu deus
que me encantaram com as músicas que
apesar da temperatura das provas
acontecerão seja austral e eu tive a
ganhar dinheiro pra ir embora pra
américa nesta altura é eu sabia que o
processo ainda mais complicado que
observa o autor não tinha promotora
janaína era que o mundo e então eu tenho
que dar meu grande ainda assim não tinha
provas nos sustentarmos a pagar não
estaria aí eu tava eu estava lá e eu
estava lá uma coisa completamente
impossível pra entrar e então não tinha
algum problema como fossem como você é
estreitar ou então de alguma forma com
que esta entrada
mesmo sem ver o pêlo é normalmente mais
facilidade
se tiver sorte quando lá chegaram para
ver uma reportagem de claudio graf e
então na altura delcídio
else phelps parece com é quando colocou
que trazia mais elas são as drogas e
tudo até fizeram sequer o bandolim essa
frase alguma coisa como pois acabou por
não se verificar a fonte
saudaram e eu o evento conseguiu talvez
sem dizer aonde vão buscá-los
então pronto será que ela andava à
procura de uma vaga queremos senado o
uso de nossa luz é claro tocávamos
imagem também foi indicado na rua
embaixo é português onde a oportunidade
até que depois viajei para são francisco
que vem casa dos velhos hippies foi
detido em sua casa pois é que é viagem
para processos que não queria muito que
é promessa que vai provar isso porque as
regras são francisco ganhou um ganhou
uma dor de barriga não descartável que
era uma delas era filha de um grande fã
do jornal bild irmã e minha filha eu
apenas estava lá
entretanto apenas as coisas nesse caso
eu não tenho o que lamentar porque é um
assunto entendendo que eu criei um
invento que já falou sobre isso e então
não deixar entrar porque sabia que ia
mostrar
o jovem fla mas eu tava tipo penal
terços é degradada
eu somente queria voltar a operar e não
deixaram entrar irá sentava de uma velha
aspecto deixa sentar e só não foi esse
passado não conseguiu arranjar um voo
foi uma amiga com um empate a compra de
roupas com final em sua barriga ficou o
eco é que depois de conseguir se entrar
no canadá caiu eu acho que sim dizer que
eu fui assaltado em san diego e naldo
encara o colo colo nesta liga e eu tenho
a minha função é essa aquisição é tudo
isso é que então o que é saudável o
livro acompanha tudo esquecer nada é
mesmo problema porque querem é tacho
possa estar uma comunidade nómada de uma
partilha não é total de conhecimentos de
alemão para ajudar o pai para filho é
isto é um ótima experiência com certeza
a gente é o candidato escolhe 15 uma vez
por ano mas o movimento que ele esteja
onde stop e escolhe uma vez por ano
lá fazem constroem um acampamento
temporário para o mês que é hoje a idéia
central e depois de outro tudo pra ficar
melhor qual estava sua mãe
ae ser mãe ela
o toque vaga
chamorro campeão olha aquele leia na pág
a campeã
ai ai ai eu sou neve bairro laguinho
praia d el rei era les dorr alegou que
as crianças tenham acreditado que gostou
bastante do porto e foi o bloco nos
apresentar a bom porto porque é
fundamental que elas não é uma voz ativa
nos tirar
e então especial e lá é nessa época
estudante que é um evento único
aeroporto que é uma mais valia na
conjuntura atual da dança e temos que
encontrar soluções alternativas para os
estudantes conseguirem poderá continuar
a frequentar o ensino superior neste
caso é uma forma de ações reais que as
respectivas com esta região e também não
acabaram concluindo
concluindo é tamanho do nosso próprio
onu não são obrigados a fazer nada por
favor nunca siga o que os outros dizem é
importante temos a nossa própria voz e
fazemos o que estava provocando as
princiapis conhecemos a nós próprios e
princípios cooperativos e uma com uma
risca